bon on va prendre une bière deux bières
s'il vous plaît
c'est une capitale de l'extrême bâti à
plus de 2500 mètres d'altitude une
destination qui fait trembler Bogota 8
millions d'habitants ici l'oxygène est
rare et la sécurité aussi au nord les
quartiers riches au sud les pauvres
entre les deux un territoire livré à la
violence cela fait 20 ans que je n'étais
pas revenu à Bogota
à l'époque Pablo Escobar était encore
vivant
Escobar le roi de la cocaïne l'homme aux
5000 assassinats
à première vue la drogue est toujours là
mais quelque chose a changé il règne
calme étrange
et je vais vite comprendre pourquoi
[Musique]
à tous les coins de rue la police veille
à moto en voiture en treillis ou en
civil 20000 hommes quatre fois plus qu'à
Paris
un simple match de football comme ce
soir Mobilis plus d'un millier de
policiers comme si tout pouvait exploser
à n'importe quel moment comme si Bogota
était un volcan toujours au bord de se
réveiller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Bogota les cendres sont encore
brûlants
je patrouillerai la nuit avec les unités
d'élite et avec les journalistes de
faits divers
[Musique]
j'irai dans les quartiers chauds à la
rencontre des prostituées et des zombies
ces fantômes toxicomanes et sans abri
je remonterai à la source de la drogue
dans les montagnes et je verrai ces
paysans qui vivent de la marijuana et de
la coca
je m'entraînerai pour échapper au
kidnapping et je me ferai tirer dessus
pour la bonne cause
je pousserai les portes de la mort et
celle de la prison
[Musique]
jeanquette est sur le pire des crimes
des milliers d'innocents tués par la
machine de l'État
si les médecins comptent les cadavres et
les familles cherchent leur disparu
[Musique]
sale temps sur Bogota
l'homme avec qui j'ai rendez-vous
fabrique justement des manteaux
imperméables très imperméables
c'est un business unique au monde une
spécialité colombienne le costume blindé
et voici l'armanie du gilet par balle
bonjour Comment ça va bien merci
bienvenue bonjour vous parlez français
alors
Carolina cavaliero 60 employés 5000
pièces par an on va visiter allez je
vous en prie
quels sont vos clients on a des polices
on a des militaires mais aussi on a des
présidents presque tous les présidents
d'Amérique du Sud on nous vêtements
on vos vêtements par exemple
au Mexique aussi on a beaucoup d'autres
on peut pas dire tous mais on a beaucoup
de vos vêtements par balle
c'est un secret bien gardé mais en
murmure que le président de Chavez du
Venezuela et surtout Barack Obama
lui-même porterait les créations maison
ça c'est le type de veste que porte des
présidents
on peut mettre une chemise et une
cravate et on le voit on le voit pas on
le voit assez 200 % discret et c'est
celle-ci c'est maintenant tous les
présidents sont en train de nous
demander de celle-ci mais aussi ils ont
des d'autres vêtements comme ça
ça c'est la taille de François Hollande
je pense donc vous devriez essayer
ça lui irait très bien
mais je crois pas qu'il a envie d'avoir
un pare-balle Miguel cavaliero c'est
taillé une réputation internationale le
roi de la haute couture par balle n'a
qu'un seul vice il propose ses invités
de leur tirer dessus
et ici on respecte les droits de l'homme
s'il te plaît choisis ta balle
[Musique]
celle-là
allez on y va
et me voici face à mon assassin j'en
connais qui se réjouirait de cette scène
[Musique]
je vais mettre la balle et l'armée
toi tu vas mettre les bras derrière
moi je vais dire un et quand je dis un
tu inspires l'air comme ça bien fort et
tu bloques ton ventre pas trop près de
la veste
1 2 3 poum
et tu expires
tu souffles seulement après le tir si tu
fais bien ça il n'y aura pas de souci
sinon tu auras un bleu
attention
les oreilles les oreilles les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
je t'avais bien dit de retenir ta
respiration ça fait mal hein
bien sûr tu n'as pas bloqué ta
respiration
et le t-shirt
j'ai été tué par Miguel cavaliero tu es
le survivant numéro 603
je ne serai pas là
[Musique]
les gilets pare-balles se vendent comme
des petits pains et on les porte surtout
la nuit
[Musique]
commissariat de Ciudad Bolivar 22h
façade de bunker les patrouilles de nuit
se préparent en tenue de camouflage la
police militaire
[Musique]
traitait bien les citoyens quand vous
ferez les perquisitions dans les lieux
publics
respectez bien les mesures de sécurité à
chaque fois que vous vous déplacerez et
à l'intérieur des bâtiments
c'est parti
[Musique]
la police militaire est lourdement armée
son rôle est de réprimer le crime
d'autres patrouilleurs en jaune vont
faire de la dissuasion c'est avec eux
que j'embarque pour ma première nuit à
Bogota
[Musique]
dans le fourgon 4 policiers sous les
ordres de l'inspecteur Helmut l'enjeu
[Musique]
il part pour la nuit avec une mission
prioritaire
c'est quoi votre boulot la nuit
on est pas mal mobilisé sur les saisies
d'armes
pour le désarmer c'est les eaux sur elle
une arme où les objets dangereux
et le samedi soir bien sûr c'est
toujours plus compliqué
car Bogota vient d'interdire les armes à
feu décision radicale quartier de Ciudad
Bolivar Helmut et ses hommes cible les
barres de nuit
[Musique]
allez on sort s'il vous plaît sortez
les clients vont tous y passer et les
policiers disposent pour traquer des
faux papiers d'un drôle de téléphone
portable
vous pouvez vérifier les identités avec
ce cellulaire vous entrez numéro c'est
ça
nous le rentrons et si la personne a des
antécédents ça apparaît tout de suite
même l'occasion judiciaire
oui s'il a un jugement en attente ou une
panne à exécuter
les clients sont plutôt coopératifs
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
contrôles c'est très bien
au moins on se sent en sécurité nous on
aime prendre un petit verre sans risque
et vous aussi bien sûr c'est mon frère
un petit coup ok
merci pour le verre avec plaisir à
bientôt
[Musique]
des armes il en reste beaucoup en
circulation et le moindre braquage peut
tourner au drame
sur ces images l'épicier esquive le tir
mais c'est le complice du tireur qui
s'effondre
ensuite l'homme fait le tour du comptoir
et a pas les pieds
ici en passant film un assassinat avec
son téléphone
parfois les tueurs à gage agissent en
plein jour il y a 1600 meurtres par an à
Bogota 4 fois plus qu'à Paris des crimes
qui alimentent les médias surtout la
nuit à la radio nationale tous les soirs
c'est le même marathon 5 heures de
direct et d'hémoglobine au micro Julian
parat la voie de la nuit
vous êtes sur nocturne à RCN notre
émission de la nuit
Roanne tient ses auditeurs en haleine
avec le sourire et droit dans ses
pantoufles
c'est quoi ce pantalon
ça c'est un pyjama un pyjama
en quoi c'est la tenue de la nuit
le pyjama tu dors bien avec
toutes les nuits je bosse de 10h du soir
à 3h du matin quand on m'a proposé
l'émission j'ai dit ok mais avec le
costume de nuit ils m'ont dit mais c'est
quoi j'ai dit bah le pyjama
et tous les auditeurs sont au courant
même le Président je le reçois comme ça
les ministres aussi et moi aussi et
Christophe aussi
[Rires]
nous sommes en direct avec notre pays et
le reste du monde aujourd'hui je suis en
compagnie de la télévision française
Christophe Christophe bienvenue dans
notre pays bonsoir bien arrivé ça va
bien bien et toi et tout c'est la
première fois que tu viens en Colombie
la seconde fois la première fois je suis
venu à Cali pour les Ferrières
tout se passe en direct et nous avons
une information qui vient de tomber à
l'aéroport
Julian a des milliers d'indiques ces
auditeurs ils appellent le standard
s'ils sont témoins d'un crime ou d'un
accident avec un tel réseau la radio
arrive souvent sur place avant la police
on vous embrasse constance
la plupart sont taxis
ce programme il marche avec nos vagues
d'informateurs
parce que les taxis en Colombie sont
jaunes
il y a aussi la vague bleue avec les
gardes de la sécurité privée et les
vigiles et la vague verte avec la police
et l'armée de notre patrie c'est une
famille une famille celle de nocturna
RCL de RCM complice de la nuit jusqu'au
petit matin et qui se présente en pyjama
en pyjama
sur le terrain la radio envoie toutes
les nuits Alexa Castagno reporter du
crime
au volant de la voiture de la chaîne ils
fonce au moindre appel des auditeurs
et les premiers à appeler sont souvent
les chauffeurs de taxi ils sont plus de
50 000 à ils ont les yeux partout
[Musique]
celui-ci a donné rendez-vous sur la
bande d'arrêt d'urgence
bonsoir ça va tu nous suis c'est lui
qu'on recherche je t'emmène chez eux et
tu pourras interviewer le papa c'est lui
qui a disparu c'est lui qu'on recherche
je t'emmène chez eux tu pourras
interviewer le papa ok on y va
à ce moment là une voiture de police
arrive à notre hauteur bonsoir bonsoir
enchanté inspecteur Castillo c'est moi
qui surveille cette zone enchanté Alexa
vous allez faire un direct dans ce
quartier et si on va suivre ce taxi pour
couvrir une histoire de disparition
un petit direct
on peut vous escorter si vous voulez
très bien merci beaucoup
ce quartier est un peu dangereux alors
ils vont nous accompagner pour que rien
ne nous arrive
[Musique]
direction le quartier du disparu ses
parents habitent une banlieue lointaine
à l'ouest de Bogota
voici leur lotissement modeste et
surproé même s'il n'y a pas grand chose
à cambrioler car Bogota le crime peut
entrer dans toutes les maisons
[Musique]
je te présente les parents
enchanté
nous allons donner l'information en
direct sur
rcné par les taxis les habitants de
Bogota et dans tout le pays
du coup toute personne qui aurait vu
votre fils peut nous appeler c'est pour
cela que j'ai besoin que vous me
racontiez exactement ce qui s'est passé
la description de sa tenue vestimentaire
je vous préviens dès qu'on passe en
direct ok merci beaucoup
la radio dans la rue et nous la faisons
sur nocturna RCN avec notre camarade
Alexis Castagno notre voie notre
journaliste dans les rues de la capitale
avec d'autres super patrouille de RCN
Alexa
bonsoir William et bonsoir à tous nos
auditeurs de Nocturne je vous salue
depuis la localité de fontven nous
sommes dans ce quartier avec la famille
d'un jeune étudiant qui a disparu jeudi
dernier
je suis avec son père William hardila et
sa mère Margarita Moreno William
dites-nous comment votre fils a disparu
que peut-on dire ce soir
qu'il est sorti de l'université à 7h du
soir et qui n'est jamais rentré à la
maison
en plein centre
Linda
dans le quartier casalinda Margarita
Moreno maman du disparu quand lui
avez-vous parlé pour la dernière fois
vous a-t-il fait part de quelque chose
d'anormal
la dernière fois que je l'ai vu c'était
le jeudi matin avant son départ vers 6h
du matin il est parti pour l'université
il m'a embrassé il est parti et je ne
l'ai plus revu
ions vous donner en direct sur le
terrain je vous retrouve en direct dans
un autre quartier de Bogota
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
merci à vous d'avoir témoigné et
l'équipe de télé vient d'arriver
merci à vous
prenez la photo pour qu'il puisse la
filmer
c'est bien pour nous cette histoire non
il faut voir ses camarades de la fac
disent qu'ils ont quitté dans le bus
pour l'instant il y a la normale
voici l'autre journaliste star de la
nuit il s'appelle Fabian mais pour tout
le monde c'est elle noctambolo le
nocturne une vedette de City TV la
chaîne de Bogota et il n'est pas le seul
sur son créneau quatre autres équipes de
télévision sont comme lui en maraude
toutes les nuits
[Musique]
elle est très riche
on est en contact permanent avec les
gens dans la rue on recueille l'info sur
le terrain
ce sont des histoires très humaines il y
a pas besoin de trouver ça sur internet
ou en lisant des communiqués de presse à
Milla
ce sont des histoires de cette Bogota au
visage humain comme on dirait
[Musique]
cet homme a un tuyau pour nos
journalistes
des jeunes il est drogue avec de la
scopolamine et les oblige ensuite avant
de la drogue
Daniel a-t-il été drogué
pas difficile en tout cas de se procurer
une dose de scopolamine il y en a
partout à Bogota il suffit de cueillir
ses fleurs et d'en faire de la poudre on
obtient de la scopolamine une substance
qui transforme les victimes en esclave
en Europe on l'appelle la drogue du
violeur
étrange journaliste m'a fait monter dans
sa voiture il est branché en permanence
sur le canal de la police
c'est quoi ça
c'est un téléphone portable n'importe
qui peut en avoir un la seule différence
c'est le mot de passe et nous on a celui
qui permet d'être sur la fréquence de la
police des ambulances des pompiers de
tous les quartiers c'est comme ça que
nous sommes tenus au courant
ça c'est interdit en France
cette nuit la pêche aux faits divers est
plutôt bonne il y a d'abord cette maison
qui menace de s'effondrer sur les
passants
plutôt dans la journée un chauffeur de
bus est venu s'il encastrer il avait
deux grammes d'alcool dans le sang
un peu plus loin autre crash avec un
autre bus dit blessé et attention un
accident peut en cacher un autre
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour éviter le
premier accident le camion est rentré
dans la voiture ce qui s'y pour voir ça
et oui
il est une heure du matin Fabienne est
toujours en chasse il lui manque un bon
crime pour boucler son reportage et
finir sa nuit
[Musique]
c'est en plein centre qu'il va le
trouver dans le quartier de la
toradencia un coupe-gorge et un bon spot
pour un fait diversifié Fabian vient de
repérer ce jeune homme il est armé d'un
bout de bois et parait menaçant regarde
il y a une patrouille à droite
vas-y vas-y vas-y suis là
[Musique]
surtout que personne ne sort de la
voiture
l'affaire n'est pas très claire mais
pour elle note en molo c'est assez pour
ouvrir le journal du lendemain
et la Bogota
[Musique]
un groupe de travestis prêt à se battre
avec des passants dans le quartier de
Santa Fe alors on est bien à 1h10 du
matin nous avons été témoins d'un
incident depuis notre voiture c'est 3
hommes avec des morceaux de bois et des
pierres veulent affronter un groupe de
travestis dans le centre de Bogota
on distingue clairement un énorme
couteau avec lequel il menace le groupe
d'hommes
[Musique]
très rapidement le travesti est encerclé
par une voiture de taxi et une
patrouille de police au croisement de la
rue 18 de l'avenue 15
finalement à 1h25 du matin la police
décide de relâcher le travesti les
autres quitteront aussi les lieux
personne ne sera arrêté
la nuit a été tranquille pour le
noctambolo mais dans cette mégapole de 8
millions d'habitants il se passe
toujours quelque chose
à Bogota le crime est dans la tête de
tout le monde avec 5 meurtres par jour
chacun a été touché de près ou de loin
alors la mairie fait ce qu'elle peut
en France on organise des journées sans
voiture
à Bogota c'est une journée sans meurtre
qui commence pour le lancement officiel
il n'y a pas foule mais tous les élus
sont là
chaque année en Colombie
15000 personnes sont tuées
ces 41 personnes assassinées toutes les
24 heures
41 morts qui pourrait être évité
en Colombie malheureusement
nous nous sommes habitués à vivre avec
la mort
[Applaudissements]
drôle de défi tenir 24 heures sans
meurtre pour lancer ce marathon les
organisateurs ont fait libérer deux
prisonniers modèles qui vont monter sur
scène
donc je crois qu'on va y arriver tout
est possible regarde on est deux
prisonniers et on va chanter c'est bien
la preuve que rien n'est impossible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
24 heures zéro mort le pari est presque
impossible à tenir dans certains
quartiers et notamment dans les olias
les ghettos de Bogota
[Musique]
il n'y en a plus de 4050 souvent c'est
juste un bout de rue parfois plusieurs
pâtés de maison
Olia ça veut dire chaudron et c'est la
drogue qui bouillonne dans ses chaudrons
là dans ses audaces on croise les
fantômes
[Musique]
des hommes au bout du rouleau dis-leur
et consommateurs de drogue on les
appelle les zombies
[Musique]
Travis
depuis l'âge de 20 ans il en a 42
aujourd'hui
tu vois nous on est des zombies
on est comme des fantômes
oui je me sens coupé de la réalité
j'ai l'impression de vivre dans un autre
monde
jamais j'aurais pensé finir comme ça
qu'est-ce que tu consommes
de la cocaïne mais je suis surtout accro
bassouko
le Basso une sorte de craque
Carlos lui est un immigré péruvien il a
28 ans
je suis toxico je consomme de la cocaïne
pour moi c'est Oya c'est l'enfer sur
Terre on y risque sa peau tu as tous les
jours tous les jours
pour y acheter de la drogue la drogue je
peux en acheter dans une Oya toute
proche je viens surtout pour vendre des
trucs ou acheter des munitions rien de
plus
des munitions
ouais j'ai une arme mais je la porte
plus la journée
il y a trop de contrôle maintenant il y
a trop de lois
autrement dit les armes sortent la nuit
le 24 heures zéro mort n'est pas gagné à
quelques rues de là un autre ghetto mais
de riche camera barbelés vigile pour
ceux qui peuvent se l'offrir la sécurité
n'a pas de prix avoir un garde du corps
est une chose courante et le devenir est
une carrière enviable
[Musique]
bienvenue à la School security ici on
n'enseigne pas la musique et c'est tant
mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour César gutheres bienvenue
à la School security l'école de
formation pour le diplôme de garde du
corps
ces argoteresse a des airs de pirates
mais il aime la discipline son école est
l'une des meilleures du monde
80ème promo de garde du corps bonjour
bonjour je suis monsieur
discipline et dignité allez 5 pompes
cette 90e promotion compte une centaine
d'élèves ils ont une vingtaine d'années
et s'ils n'ont pas choisi la police ça
n'est pas par manque de diplôme garde du
corps c'est plus risqué mais c'est mieux
payé
[Musique]
combien peuvent-ils gagner c'est bien
payé il y a deux types de salaires
ceux employés par l'État
et puis par le ministère de l'Intérieur
cela ils peuvent gagner l'équivalent de
400 euros
et ceux qui travaillent pour la sécurité
privée ils vont gagner de 1200 à 1600
euros par mois
1600 euros c'est plus de 8 fois le
salaire moyen et c'est le double de ce
que touche un policier
César en vient de la police il était
dans les renseignements à l'époque
d'Escobar et des attentats en pleine
ville
j'étais enquêteur dans la pire période
de la Colombie fin des années 80 début
des années 90 c'était vraiment chaud et
qu'est-ce qu'il est arrivé à ton œil
de travail
j'ai perdu la vue le droite au cours
d'une mission et on a cette situation
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que j'ai perdu un œil
c'est le boulot pour ce qui est à voir
ça me suffit maintenant
César est une référence dans ce métier
il me donne un cours particulier
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
si je me dégage et je me positionne pour
être prêt à dégainer mon arme et
maintenant imaginons que j'ai mon café à
la main mais comment fait-on alors dans
ce cas je dois jeter mon café comme ça
pour pouvoir dégainer
il va falloir refaire du café
ses élèves vont bientôt rejoindre les
rangs de la sécurité privée borota
compte plus de 7000 gardes du corps une
des plus fortes concentrations du monde
[Musique]
militaire et j'ai décidé de m'orienter
vers ce boulot ça m'a toujours plu je
crois qu'on peut dire que j'ai ça dans
le sang
je sais pas si c'est l'adrénaline mais
j'aime pouvoir bouger prendre des
risques écoutez risque je suis servi
nos futurs clients risquent d'être
séquestrés ou braquer nous on est là
pour leur apporter la tranquillité et la
sécurité
je te propose un exercice tu vas jouer
la personnalité à protéger d'accord rien
de plus naturel pour moi comme chez les
troupes d'élite les entraînements se
rapprochent au plus près du réel
d'habitude on tire avec de vraies balles
avec moi ce sera blanc
je suis avec
très protégé
s'il vous plaît monsieur on y va mais
garde du corps ne connaissent pas le
scénario à l'avance ils ne savent pas à
quel moment César va les mettre à
l'épreuve
bon on va prendre une bière deux bières
s'il vous plaît
allez allez allez
[Applaudissements]
on y va on y va on y va
merci merci à tous merci beaucoup
il est 17h l'opération 24 heures zéro
mort est à mi-course cette nuit je vais
repartir en patrouille mais avant je
fais un peu de shopping dans ces
boutiques on peut acheter toute la
panoplie des gendarmes et des voleurs
uniformes un signe et même note
ça c'est la casquette de capitaine de
police
et ici j'ai des menottes
les menottes ça m'a coûté 30 euros quand
même
plus que 10 heures avant que nous
s'achève l'opération 24 heures zéro mort
[Musique]
je suis en voiture avec Alexia le
reporter radio
[Musique]
soudain un corps au milieu de la rue
règlement de compte
il est mort non non non
ainsi
sur la route
va sur trottoir tu risques de te faire
renverser
[Musique]
10 minutes plus tard alerte sur la radio
de la police un chauffeur de taxi vient
d'être assassiné la réaction de la
profession est immédiate des centaines
de taxis convergent vers les lieux du
crime
et voilà voilà
il manifeste leur indignation contre
l'insécurité
ici la nuit dans les rues de Bogota
on arrive voilà la scène du crime
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
la pollution scientifique nous tient à
distance c'est le 14e chauffeur de taxi
assassiné cette année
[Musique]
dans ce coin de la capitale
il faut lutter pour la vie tous les
jours tu sais Alexa
comment ça va bien bien colonel bonsoir
voici le leader syndical des taxines il
vient reconnaître le corps
la colère monte trop de morts et le
sentiment d'être seul
que s'est-il passé
notre camarade a été poignardée il était
handicapé
ils l'ont poignardé à l'intérieur du
taxi puis ils l'ont sorti et ils lui ont
tiré dessus
il a dû agoniser au sol
l'opération 24 heures zéro mort est un
échec bilan pour Bogota trois meurtres
revue de presse le lendemain matin
je cherche des nouvelles du jeune
étudiant disparu
pas une ligne
alors je reprends contact avec ses
parents William et Margarita un témoin
aurait vu leur fils dans ce quartier
on a reçu un appel pour nous dire que
notre fille s'était passé par ici des
gens l'auraient vu
William et Margarita ne peuvent compter
que sur eux-mêmes pour rechercher leur
enfant la police est totalement absente
oh mon dieu que Dieu vous aide
gardez la foi merci Madame excusez-moi
vous avez peut-être rencontré ce gamin
sur votre chemin
non madame
que vous auriez vu ce gamin par ici
quel âge a-t-il
pour leur signaler sa présence ici
tu l'as pas vu
si vous voulez vous pouvez coller votre
avis de recherche à l'entrée c'est comme
ça qu'ils ont retrouvé une petite fille
en mettant juste une photo à l'entrée
les gens l'ont vu et ils ont retrouvé la
gamine
et on a dû lui faire prendre de la
scopolamine c'est une drogue
hallucinogène
c'est probablement ce qui est arrivé à
notre gare
[Applaudissements]
leur fils est-il encore vivant
William et Margarita imagine le pire je
les reverrai dans quelques jours
en attendant je pars explorer le Bronx
on en parle depuis mon arrivée et on me
dit que c'est le pire de tous les
quartiers de Bogota
impossible d'y filmer et même dimanche
paraît-il
pour s'y rendre c'est très simple passez
devant cette caserne de l'armée
et vous y êtes
incroyable contraste en quelques mètres
ordre et chaos
le Bronx c'est la Cour des Miracles très
vite nous sommes repérés
un guetteur a fait son travail
il y a quelques mois un policier habillé
en clochard a tenté de s'infiltrer dans
le Bronx il a été débusqué et abattu
[Musique]
régulièrement tous les 6 mois les forces
anti-émeutes tente de nettoyer le
quartier mais à chaque fois le Bronx
renaît de ses cendres
il y a trop d'argent en jeu une demi
tonnes de cocaïne serait écoulée ici
chaque mois et de la marijuana
et ce fameux bassuko mélange de cocaïne
et de produits chimiques un cocktail qui
ronge le cerveau et rend fou
abogota le business de la drogue fait
vivre beaucoup de gens et en tue presque
autant il a sa légende Pablo Escobar le
roi de la cocaïne sanguinaire et
pourtant populaire
avec Escobar en vedette la télévision
faite en ce moment un carton d'audience
Escobar le patron du mal le feuilleton
rassemble chaque soir deux
téléspectateurs sur 3 un record
il faut dire que l'histoire d'Escobar
est stupéfiante gamin des rues devenu
septième fortune mondiale Escobar est le
plus grand trafiquant de drogue de
l'histoire
dans cette vie tout problème à sa
solution
[Musique]
la série a de gros moyens et les
reconstitutions sont fidèles
1989 le favori de la présidentielle est
assassiné par les hommes d'Escobar
voici l'image d'archives
[Musique]
et la même scène dans le feuilleton
[Applaudissements]
et là le meurtre d'un journaliste
directeur du plus gros quotidien
colombien
fiction et réalité
le feuilleton a fait débat complaisant
pour ceux qui se souviennent des 5000
victimes d'Escobar mais pour beaucoup
Escobar c'est Robin des bois
car Escobar a redistribué un peu il a
fait construire des maisons pour les
pauvres
son enterrement sera celui d'un saint
mon voyage se poursuit dans cette
Colombie qui n'arrive pas à sortir de la
malédiction du crime je ne suis pas au
bout de mes surprises je vais monter en
altitude chez les Indiens de la vallée
de la Kaoka là où pousse la drogue je
vais entrer en prison pour un parloir
avec un terroriste je vais visiter la
mort avec son effrayant puzzle l'humain
et je vais écouter le pire des
témoignages celui d'une mère dont
l'enfant a été sacrifié
[Musique]
Escobar était du cartel de Medellin
aujourd'hui c'est le cartel de Cali qui
mène la danse
je prends la route vers le sud
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai rendez-vous à pétécoï
le quartier le plus violent de Cali
ces rues ont l'air calme mais en
meurtrier commis toutes les heures
pète les couilles a inspiré le scénario
d'un film pas tout à fait comme les
autres
[Musique]
live storia
au cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici le réalisateur
Oscar inkapier
[Musique]
et voici ses acteurs tous du quartier
tous criminels
au début je voulais juste te faire un
film pour le ciné un truc pour divertir
tu vois et au fil du tournage je me suis
rendu compte que ce film devenait un
projet social et que ça pouvait changer
les comportements des habitants les
aider à changer de vie même
c'est dans ces rues coscar a fait son
casting dealer getter tueur apticouille
il y a tous les profils et il crève
l'écran voici les vidéos de casting
[Musique]
tu as quel âge 35 ans ta taille
tu sais faire quoi chanter danser et me
taper des gonzesses et fumer de l'herbe
tu as une spécialité le chant la danse
ma spécialité c'est la gâchette
c'est mon truc
vous faites comme si vous étiez en train
de jouer
allez allez allez pendant les
répétitions pas besoin d'accessoires les
acteurs connaissent les gestes par cœur
et maintenant tu l'attaques par derrière
allez
[Rires]
John James a grandi dans un grand
aujourd'hui il fait l'acteur
la plupart de mes amis ne sont plus là
ils sont morts tu as perdu combien de
tes amis près de 30 amis sans compter
mon propre frère qui a été assassiné ah
oui ton frère
mon frère oui et aussi des cousins et
des beaux frères pourquoi
pour des conflits internes
un conflit armé une lutte entre
différents quartiers
quand tu n'as pas de boulot ici le seul
recours c'est le trafic de drogue
et pour contrôler ce trafic les jeunes
s'affrontant entre eux tu vois
ça se passe comme ça
le tournage de ce film associe
d'incroyable que la réalité à très vite
rattrapé la fiction son interprète
principal a été assassiné puis le
suivant puis le suivant et encore une
fois 4 au total
les voici dans la même scène
regardez bien voici le premier
interprète il sera tué quelques jours
plus tard
le second
le troisième
[Musique]
et le quatrième qui lui aussi finira
sous les balles
ça a été un drame ce film un vrai drame
pour toi 5 de tes interprètes ont été
tués
[Musique]
le tournage nous a pris plus de 6 ans 6
années pendant lesquelles on a tous
tissé des relations de travail mais
aussi d'amitié
du coup tu as dû chercher à chaque fois
un acteur qui ressemblait aux précédents
et puis inquiéter grand et gros
à chaque fois qu'on a changé d'acteur
moi je voulais que ça se voit il était
pas question de trouver un acteur qui
ressemble à celui d'avant il fallait que
ça se voit pour que le téléspectateur
soit interpellé pour que c'est mort ait
du sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la jeunesse du quartier n'a pas d'autre
raison le gang la drogue sauver sa peau
vas-y quand même le but de chaque gang
c'est de contrôler un territoire pour
vendre de la drogue c'est aussi basique
que ça et leur but c'est de protéger
leur territoire ils s'entretuent s'il y
a un gang adverse qui tente de vendre de
la drogue chez eux et ils font du racket
ils prélèvent une sorte d'impôts si tu
ne fais pas il te descende où il menace
ceux qui ne devraient pas être sur leur
territoire ici toute façon tout se règle
un coup de fusil ou de revolver il y a
des morts toutes les semaines
malheureusement
[Musique]
difficile de ne pas vendre de drogue
quand on vit dans le pays qui en produit
le plus au monde je vais remonter à la
source au royaume de la coca et de la
marijuana
le chaouka territoire indien
la zone a l'air sensible l'armée et sur
le qui-vive
vous allez où
et vous êtes très international ah ok
merci
quelques kilomètres après le checkpoint
une épicerie au bord de la route et bien
en évidence un gros sac d'herbe voilà
voilà ce qu'il vaut de l'or en
Occident et qui ici vaut 50 € quoi il y
a un demi kilo une livre de
elles sont énormément
on fait rêver quelques occidentaux à moi
ça c'est le travail d'une journée
ambiance bon enfant pourtant les narcos
ne sont pas loin
impossible de voyager dans ces montagnes
sans un guide
Damien Fellous vit en Colombie depuis 5
ans il est photographe
attention aux apparences dans ce paysage
bucolique la violence est partout et on
ne cultive pas que du café
entre des arbres
c'est vraiment un verre très particulier
toutes les fermes non quasiment pas
toutes toutes maisons beaucoup ont un
petit carré comme ça de culture illicite
marijuana ou coca parce que le reste
c'est les prix sur le marché tellement
bac ils arrivent pas ils savent pas
vivre quoi avec ça donc avec la coca ça
permet de joindre les deux bouts c'est
le beurre dans les épinards
une mosaïque de petits producteurs avec
ses parcelles individuelles la culture
est bien enracinée
bonormalan la Colombie produit la moitié
de la droge
[Musique]
là on a clairement de l'herbe de la
marijuana il semble que ce soit des
graines échappées dans le champ qui soit
tombé là et puis qui est irrigué ce
champ il y a quand même pas mal de plans
elles sont pas très hautes mais on est
en période de sécheresse et en général
ce genre de truc là
donc il y a pas de fleurs il y a rien
fumé pour l'instant
Silence ça pousse la région vit de la
drogue c'est sûr mais on en parle pas
Gustavo et paysan il accepte de nous
ouvrir sa porte
je vis du café de la banane du manioc de
ce qui pousse quoi
et tu fais du cannabis aussi
c'est interdit et de la coca la coca oui
c'est possible pour des infusions ça
c'est pas interdit non si c'est pour
faire des remèdes
je n'irai pas plus loin dans mes
questions Gustavo préfère me montrer
l'usage traditionnel de la coca
feuille par feuille tu risques
d'arracher les bourgeons
et du coup ça poussera plus
on va aller les griller
de la postale
je te suis
[Musique]
difficile à croire mais ces quelques
feuilles
sont la source du trafic le plus violent
au monde
voilà elles sont prêtes
elles sont presque sèches
et on les mange comme ça oui comment
est-ce qu'on les mange
il faut mâcher
il faut que je marche longtemps non pas
forcément
ça endort la bouche ensuite tu peux les
recracher
ok je vais les recracher
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le territoire des
Indiens NASA et voici Toribio la petite
ville la plus proche
sur les murs des milliers d'impacts
car pas de chance pour les Indiens Tori
bio et pile sur la ligne de front entre
l'armée et les Farcs
les Farcs rappelez-vous Ingrid
Bettencourt a été le rotache pendant 6
ans les phares restent encore de
marxisme ils sont la plus vieille
guérilla au monde et c'est la drogue qui
les finances
en disant Toribio a été attaqué par les
phares plus de 400 fois presque une fois
par semaine et à chaque fois ce poste
militaire est prêt pour
ces images ont été filmées il y a deux
ans les phares tirent des hauteurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un soldat vient d'être touché il est
évacué vers une épicerie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'armée va réagir en construisant ce
bunker à toute épreuve les phares vont
l'attaquer à la dynamite
juillet 2011 un bus piégé explose le
bunker était visé mais ce sont les
maisons aux alentours qui sont soufflées
trois morts
70 blessés
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque Damien le photographe a
couvert l'attentat
c'est le plus gros attentat qui a été
commis à l'intérieur du village c'est un
des plus gros et en tout cas c'est un de
ceux qui a le plus affecté la population
civile ce qui est né relis les Indiens
c'est d'être pris entre deux feux dans
le conflit qui trouve les concernent pas
tant que ça quoi et donc ils ont payé
quand même le prix il paye un prix très
très lourd tous les acteurs s'entraînent
du côté de l'armée ou de la police on
les suspecte des auxiliaires presque de
la guérilla la guérilla les suspecte des
informateurs de la police ou en tout cas
le reproche de vouloir les sortir eux
aussi de leur territoire les
paramilitaires comme ils essayent aussi
de récupérer leur terrain et de
récupérer leur territoire les
paramilitaires qui sont au service des
grandes entreprises minières ou des
grands propriétaires terriens les
assassin aussi on va dire ils sont
vraiment les victimes de tous les
acteurs du conflit
en disant 6000 Indiens ont été tués
aujourd'hui leur chef accuse
Félicien novalencia dirige le conseil
régional indigène
pas mal de soucis ces derniers temps
avec l'armée la guérilla les
paramilitaires
et que vous vous retrouvez au fond piégé
au milieu de tout ça
comment est-ce que vous voyez les choses
en haut dans les montagnes et il y a les
champs de coca ces cultures se sont
surtout les Farcs qui les contrôlent et
c'est là où aussi que sont installés les
laboratoires pour transformer la cocaïne
tout ça c'est juste au dessus de notre
territoire nous on s'est battus pour
qu'il s'en aille mais il résiste il
produisent sa Nao et il redescend de la
drogue par là mais c'est d'en bas que
sont montés aussi les produits chimiques
pour fabriquer la coque du coup voilà la
question pour venir jusqu'ici tu dois
passer par des barrages militaires tu
les as vu et dans cette zone il y a
encore plus de Checkpoint militaire en
haut tu as les FARC les militaires et la
police en bas les paramil mais les
produits chimiques montent et la cocaïne
descend alors pourquoi tout le monde
ferme les yeux sur ce trafic que tout le
monde voit
le lendemain de l'attentat au bus piégé
les Indiens de Toribio décide de s'en
prendre au militaire après tout ce sont
eux qui attirent les Farcs dans la vie
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes sur un territoire qui ne vous
appartient pas vous devriez avoir honte
vous devriez vous sentir coupable je ne
bougerai pas
l'état nous a envoyé ici pour vous
protéger la Terre est à nous
on nous piétine de tous les côtés
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
combien de temps devrait être encore
versé pour que vous partiez
sans arme aucune les Indiens réussissent
un exploit les soldats s'enfuient
victoire symbolique il reviendront une
semaine plus tard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
contre les phares ou contre l'armée les
Indiens ne font pas le poids même s'ils
ont leur propre police la garde indigène
ce sont ces hommes qui ont poussé dehors
les militaires
edgar est l'un d'entre eux un policier
non violent avec une panoplie de scout
pour être plus efficace
nous sommes des acteurs de la paix pas
de la guerre s'il y a des blessés on
vient leur porter secours quel que soit
leur camp
mais notre but c'est de protéger la vie
menaces de morts que ce soit de la
guérilla des milices ou de l'armée la
police
la police et l'armée aussi
les Farcs sont tout autour ils savent
même sûrement qu'une équipe de
télévision française est à Toribio pas
question de les approcher
des guérir au je vais en rencontrer à
Bogota à la prison de la modèle c'est la
pierre de la capitale on y entre en
tremblant
tu as peur
les nouveaux prisonniers entre à pied on
les a menottés les uns aux autres comme
des bannières à l'intérieur ils sont
11000 pour 3000 places d'après les
organisations humanitaires c'est une
jungle pour y survivre il faut se battre
ou avoir la foi
j'ai demandé un parloir avec un membre
des Farcs voici Yoann Calderon alias
René
son nom de code dans la guérilla Yoann a
été condamné pour terrorisme il purge
une peine de 8 ans et tu appartient
vraiment au FARC ouais bien sûr alors
c'est vrai
qu'ici à l'université
l'armée a dit aux médias que moi j'étais
un chef des phares
mais c'est la vérité
c'est pour ça que je parle d'un montage
tout est faux
ils disent que c'est moi qui recruté
ils disent que c'est moi qui financais
les mouvements bolivariens les milices
bolivarienne dans les universités
ils disent que j'étais du Parti
communiste clandestin
que j'étais le bras droit d'un
commandant important des phares et que
j'étais un lien avec le front
mais tout ça c'est faux
Johan se considère comme un prisonnier
politique mais en Colombie la politique
et le crime ne sont jamais très éloignés
pour financer la lutte armée les Farcs
se sont lancés dans le trafic de drogue
et le kidnapping plus de 10000 otages
sont passés entre leurs mains derrière
le discours révolutionnaire un business
crapuleux
parmi tous ces otages certains ont
émulsé et quelques visages sont restés
dans les mémoires celui de siggy Fredo
Lopez par exemple ancien député s'étend
de captivité
il est libéré quelques mois après Ingrid
Bettencourt et il porte encore les
bottes qu'il avait dans la jambe
retrouvailles avec ses fils
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moment de liesse dans tout le
pays
[Musique]
de Lopez est arrêté le voici à nouveau
prisonnier mais cette fois de la justice
colombienne
ça a été très dur ma famille a beaucoup
souffert j'ai d'abord été séquestré
pendant 7 ans 7 ans retenu par les
phares et après c'est la justice qui m'a
séquestré ils ont traîné mon nom dans la
boue
de quoi accusait-on l'ancien otage
d'avoir organisé son propre enlèvement
bref d'avoir appartenu au FARC
c'était le 11 avril 2002 ce jour-là les
guérir au des phares se font passer pour
des soldats et qui nappe 12 députés il
filme leur opération et parmi ces
députés Sigui Fredo Lopez
le voici avec la moustache visiblement
apeuré
Lopez sera le seul survivant les 11
autres députés seront exécutés
et voici les images qui l'accusent dix
ans plus tard d'être le cerveau de
l'opération des images du briefing des
phares la veille du jour J le chef
prépare ses troupes on ne le voit pas
sauf un instant son nez entre dans le
champ de la caméra pour la police
s'éclaire c'est le nez du député Lopez
les experts en morphologie affirment que
le profil de son nez coïncide sur les
deux vidéos
aujourd'hui l'ex député Lopez est libre
et totalement blanchi mais il vit avec
des gardes du corps la société
colombienne est l'une des plus violentes
au monde
ici on tue pour n'importe quelle motif
pour un mot pour une différence ici on
ne connaît pas la tolérance
nous avons connu beaucoup de périodes
violentes oui très violentes
et ces douleurs accumulées au fil de
notre histoire
se transmettent de génération en
génération
et les victimes ne sont que des détails
notre démocratie les oublie
entre les phares et le gouvernement
c'est depuis toujours la salle guerre
avec ses coutures une guerre qui a fait
aussi des milliers de disparus un fléau
colombien enlevé et tué par la guérilla
ou par les narcotrafiquants ils ont
laissé leur famille dans le doute ni
otages ni vivant ni mort
[Musique]
et maintenant le cas de villefredo
Pernaut
j'espère savoir un jour la vérité pour
mon fils
il a disparu sur le trajet qui va de
chez nous à l'école
15 jours après quelqu'un m'a répondu sur
son portable
il m'a dit qu'il avait été enlevé
et que jamais plus je ne leur verrai
ça fait 8 ans
des stands pour accueillir les familles
mille policiers sur place l'État a vu
grand pour cette journée spéciale
disparue mais comment mener autant
d'enquêtes il y a plus de 60 000
personnes disparues dans le pays
[Musique]
parfois on retrouve les disparus mais il
est trop tard
un coup de fil souvent à l'autre bout du
pays
un corps correspond au signalement
[Musique]
et c'est la même scène macabre les
ouvriers exument le cadavre le chagrin
d'une mère d'un frère d'un fils les
photographes de l'identité judiciaire la
fin d'un doute et le début d'un deuil
[Musique]
cette histoire Luz Marina avec eux
pendant presque un an elle a cherché son
fils partout dans Bogota Luz Marina
élève seul ses enfants famille sans
histoire appartement modeste
bonjour ça va
enchanté Marina
à espérer retrouver son fils vivant
jusqu'à cet appel de la mort
le corps de son fils Léonardo venait
d'être retrouvé vêtue en uniforme des
phares à des milliers de kilomètres
[Musique]
quand je suis arrivé à la mort et ils
m'ont montré la photo de mon fils
il a reçu très impact de balle et sur
les 13 2 on traversé son visage et l'ont
défiguré
Leonardo était handicapé mental alors
Luz Marina a du mal à admettre ce qu'on
lui raconte
terroriste je leur ai dit quoi ils m'ont
dit oui il est mort en tenue de combat
et on l'a liquidé parce que c'est le
chef d'une organisation narcotérisme
c'est impossible
pour une raison médicale toute simple
mon fils est handicapé à plus de 50%
mon fils ne sait pas lire il ne sait pas
écrire il ne connaît pas la valeur de
l'argent
vous croyez qu'une personne dans cette
étape peut diriger un groupe tel que
vous le décrivez on m'a dit mais madame
c'est le rapport de l'armée
c'est là que j'ai eu la conviction que
c'était l'armée qui avait assassiné mon
fils et là j'ai mesuré l'ampleur du
mensonge
assassiné pour les bienfaits de la
statistique car pour chaque guerrier aux
morts les militaires touchent une prime
une médaille et un bonus de congé
pour faire du chiffre et arrondir leur
fin de mois des militaires auraient
assassiné des innocents avant de leur
passer un uniforme de Guerriero on
appellera ses victimes des faux positifs
le scandale est énorme
combien il y en a-t-il eu chaque mois
Luz Marina manifeste avec d'autres mers
vêtus de blanc il est sur quelle photo
c'est le petit qui est là en train de
chanter
il avait 16 ans
voilà mon fils
[Musique]
ils avaient entre 16 et 32 ans tous
d'origine modeste on pensait sans doute
que leur mort passerait inaperçu c'était
compter sans la détermination de ces
femmes
[Musique]
tout a commencé
là où tout finit à la morgue de Bogota
voici l'un des premiers à avoir tout
compris compris qu'un crime impensable
était commis à grande échelle le docteur
Pedro morales
au cours de ces autopsies il voyait des
grilleraux chaussées avec deux bottes du
même pied ou des gauchers qui avaient
l'arme dans la main droite médecin
légiste à Bogota on ne chôme pas
[Musique]
voilà des cadavres ou du moins des
squelettes ça peut être des victimes
des guerriers
et puis surtout les faux positifs cela
ne sont pas encore identifiés ils n'ont
pas de nom
ils n'ont pas non
pour la plupart nous tentons de
reconstituer les squelettes on s'appuie
sur ce qu'on a trouvé
là vous pouvez voir que c'est bien
reconstitué on a le corps presque en
entier
dans chacune de ces boîtes des restes
humains des squelettes souvent
incomplets le docteur morales espère les
rendre un jour à leur famille
nous en avons des milliers des milliers
mais tout ça est en cours c'est
l'honneur d'un grand pays de faire ça
et c'est aussi par respect pour les
victimes et pour nos concitoyens
nous voulons croire que nous pouvons
résoudre ces affaires on s'avoue jamais
vaincu même si on nous dit mais pourquoi
vous faites tous travail pourquoi est-ce
que ça coûte si cher pourquoi tant de
personnel
c'est vrai que nous comptons de l'argent
je vais vous poser une colle qui nous
donne l'argent d'après vous
et bien c'est paradoxal c'est le
gouvernement qui nous paye pour
poursuivre nos investigations
même si c'est justement nos
investigations qui risque de lui
retomber dessus
alors nous lui sommes très
reconnaissants et les victimes aussi
qui au sein de l'appareil d'État a
organisé ses crimes qui les a couverts
3500 faux positifs ont déjà été
répertoriés
[Musique]
totalement
et
donne des c'est comme si j'étais une
morte vivante il me manque une partie de
ma vie
raconter l'histoire de mon fils c'est
dur
surtout les conditions dans lesquelles
ils l'ont assassiné
et je suis d'autant plus triste que je
ne sais pas comment récupérer l'autre
moitié du cadavre de mon fils
alors oui je pleure
oui chaque jour chaque jour
parce que rentrer dans sa chambre
sans manger et voir sa chaise vide
oui c'est dur
oui je me doute que c'est dur
parce que quand quelqu'un me frappe à la
porte ou comme lui frappait je m'attends
à le voir entrer
je l'attends tous les jours
c'est la fille de Luz Marina qui a signé
les paroles de cette chanson mère et
fille ont chacune leur façon de demander
justice
Luz Marina elle a entamé des études
d'avocat
[Musique]
S
si la justice passe ce sera grâce à cet
homme il circule en voiture blindée
c'est l'avocat des victimes
Franck castagnida ces phrases sont
lourdes
leur logique c'était d'enlever des
innocents dont personne ne se souciait
et que personne n'aurait recherché
ils ont choisi les gens les plus pauvres
les gens les plus isolés
ils ont été séquestrés enlevés à leur
famille vêtue en uniforme assassiné
horriblement par les forces de l'ordre
et déclarait mort ensuite au combat
en face d'une réalité macabre la force
publique colombienne l'armée la police
et les services de renseignement mais
principalement l'armée colombienne ont
assassiné des civils pour pouvoir
démontrer que le gouvernement était en
train de gagner la guerre
alors question qui était ministre de la
Défense à l'époque des faits réponse
Juan Manuel Santos l'actuel président de
République Indian je comprends pourquoi
tu as besoin de garde du corps et
pourquoi tu es une voiture blindée comme
celle-ci
la dernière menace que j'ai reçue
c'était l'été dernier il y a quelques
mois à peine
tuer des innocents pour faire du chiffre
si on en est arrivé là c'est que le
système est rongé jusqu'à l'os par la
corruption une faillite morale qui
révolte la jeunesse ce matin 20 000
étudiants défilent dans le centre de
Bogota les slogans vise la police et
l'armée en face les forces anti-émeutes
se déploient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Robocop contre gauchiste très vite la
manif dégénère
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas le droit vous êtes des
gros porcs vous faites couler votre
propre sang gros porc
[Musique]
il faudra sans doute de très longues
années avant que les Colombiens ne
reprennent confiance dans leurs
institutions
[Musique]
ce que j'ai vu ces derniers jours ne me
rend pas très optimiste et je repense à
Daniel le jeune disparu cela fait 10
jours maintenant que ses parents le
recherchent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de ce jeune homme que nous recherchions
sur RCN il faut un contrat son corps
était retrouvé dans un fossé de la
capitale de la République
d'après les premières informations qui
nous sont parvenues on a retrouvé aucune
marque de torture ni trace de violence
pour le moment le corps de Daniel
hardila a été transporté à la mort et
c'est là qu'on établira les causes de la
mort de cet adolescent
cette histoire se termine par un drame
la plupart du temps on en reste là mais
ses parents en ont décidé autrement
il demande justice pour leur enfant leur
drame plus de 10000 familles le vivant
Colombie
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont eu un
proche disparu
c'est un coup dur les parents sont sous
le choc et personne n'est là pour les
soutenir pas un policier pas un élu
juste des journalistes
vous vous êtes senti seul pas trop aidé
dans vos recherches
nous-mêmes nos familles
familiaris
n'ont rien fait pour accélérer l'enquête
vous craignez de ne jamais connaître la
vérités ne nous donnent aucun espoir
elle ne semble pas vouloir continuer
l'enquête
ok merci
on reste à votre disposition merci
beaucoup
dès que nous avons des résultats on vous
appelle
ah oui s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on doit aller jusqu'au bout il doit y
avoir au moins une ou deux personnes
arrêtées et un juge qui disent vous êtes
condamné à 25 ans de prison pour meurtre
[Musique]
la fin de mon séjour approche je
commence à aimer Bogota
cette ville qui essaie de tourner une
lourde page pas simple avec toute cette
misère
[Musique]
depuis mon arrivée je suis frappé par le
nombre de prostituées il y en a 35000
dans la capitale colombienne
[Musique]
filmé dans un bordel est impossible
je reste dans la voiture
et puis je rencontre Maria elle est
d'accord pour parler mais un homme nous
surveille
et elle a peur de se faire balancer
tu sais que je vais le faire
je vais avoir 20 ans je fais ça depuis
l'âge de 14 ans
je suis parti très jeune de chez moi et
je connais aucun autre boulot et ça je
sais faire
je voulais devenir policière mais ce n'a
pas été possible
et tu voudrais arrêter
oui j'ai souvent voulu le faire mais ce
n'est pas évident de sortir de ce milieu
surtout quand tu es seul et que tu as
deux enfants
j'aimerais faire autre chose mais ça va
pas être facile
le quartier rouge s'appelle tolérancia
tolérance un endroit glauque et violent
une mine de faits divers pour un
journaliste comme Alexa et pourtant même
ici on fait des rencontres
réconfortantes
bonjour Marina ça va bien bonjour je te
présente Christophe enchanté Marina vit
ici dans Santa Fe elle s'occupe des
enfants c'est un peu comme une nounou de
nuit avec les enfants du quartier
c'est une femme très connue ici tout le
monde l'adore mais ce sont les enfants
de qui ce sont les enfants des
travailleurs social des travailleurs
sociaux oui les prostituées
les travailleuses du sexe les
travailleuses sexuels Marina s'occupe
des enfants pendant que leur mère bosse
dans la rue
comment ça c'est fait
ça fait un moment que je m'occupe des
enfants il y a une fille une amie elle
est très connue dans le quartier elle a
eu un bébé et m'a demandé de m'en
occuper
je l'ai gardé plusieurs fois et par
bouche à oreille elle a emmener d'autres
copines et ainsi de suite
il y en a combien 35 35 35 enfants
à peu près mais je les ai pas tous le
même jour
sur ce lit je peux en mettre 4 et des
tout petits
[Musique]
métis
c'est le roi ici le roi oui il est une
histoire particulière la maman l'a
laissé il avait 8 jours elle vient de
temps en temps
elle demande de ses nouvelles et elle
repart et elle me dit demain je vais
venir le reprendre mais ça va faire
bientôt trois ans qu'il est ici je crois
qu'elle ne le reprendra jamais
[Musique]
maman moi je suis ton petit chéri oui tu
es mon chouchou celle qui peuvent vous
paye c'est ça
oui celle qui peuvent cette petite fille
ça fait un moment qu'elle est là je ne
sais pas où est sa maman
elle a un petit frère que je garde dans
mon autre maison j'ai encore d'autres
enfants là-bas c'est une de mes employés
qui s'en occupent et qui dort sur place
lui il a grandi ici je m'en suis occupée
c'est toujours ma maman pour moi
c'est elle qui a pris soin de moi
c'est un cœur unique et qui est bon
tous ces enfants lui seront aussi
reconnaissants
nous l'aimons tous dans le quartier vous
êtes une lueur d'espoir dans un quartier
plutôt difficile
c'est un quartier très très comment dire
un quartier chaud
mais pas à cause du climat
lui c'est vraiment un petit amour
[Musique]
que deviendront ses enfants de la rue
quel pays construiront-ils
[Musique]
je repars de Colombie avec des visages
en mémoire le visage de Daniel le jeune
disparu et celui de ses parents seul
dans leur douleur
le visage magnifique de louche Marina
les soldats qui ont tué son enfant pour
faire du chiffre sont en prison pour
longtemps bientôt peut-être l'état
colombien lui-même devra rendre des
comptes
je ne suis pas prêt d'oublier ces
quartiers coupe-gorge et ses zombies au
bout du rouleau Javier Carlos sont
toujours accro au bassuko je repense aux
député Lopez aux tâches pendant 7 ans et
accusés d'avoir organisé son propre
enlèvement il vient de recevoir des
excuses officielles et puis il y a les
Indiens NASA dans leur montagne victimes
parmi les victimes depuis ma visite ils
ont été une fois de plus bombardé par
les Farcs trois morts de plus avant
qu'un jour peut-être le pays de la
cocaïne finisse par retrouver la paix
[Musique]